if we all went a little nuts during the
co lockdowns it's absolutely true that
some of us including many of our
country's leaders and people in the
media went absolutely batshit crazy
often to disastrous ends exactly why
that happened is the subject of author
John Ronson's latest season of things
fell apart a podcast that explores the
Deep origins of today's culture wars in
controversies panics and delusions from
decades ago I talked with Ronson about
how the creation of a fake medical
condition called excited delirium in
1988 ultimately led to the death of
George Floyd in 2020 how law enforcement
fixations on white supremacy warped the
investigation into a plot to kidnap
Michigan Governor Gretchen Whitmer and
how the director of the massively
influential planemic documentaries was
actually rewriting Star Wars Ronson is
best known as the author of The Men Who
Stare at Goats an account of a US army
unit that tried to perfect Paran normal
Power was like walking through walls and
ended up influencing interrogation
techniques in Guantanamo and so you've
been publicly shamed which helped to
find cancel culture just as it was
becoming widespread via social
media John Ronson thanks for talking to
reason Nick
hello so uh things fell apart you just
released the second season there are two
seasons tell me you know what what's
your vision of the series uh both s uh
season one and two and then we'll talk
more about season two since it's just
that sure I guess the image in my head
is you know you go to a party and the
party has gone really badly and when you
turn up everyone's like yelling at each
other and you've got no idea how it
started uh and I think you know so I
wanted to tell these stories that go
right back into the you know the history
you know the the the Pebbles thrown in
the ponds The Origin moments that tiny
little human moment that then expanded
and expanded and then just engulfed soet
what I love about the series is you know
both season one and two is that you go
back to you know you kind of wind the
tape back mostly to the 80s where a lot
of this like a lot of basic culture War
issues you can locate the origin point
of this is when it became kind of
recognized in the fashion it is and then
it kind of like a retrov virus kind of
disappears and then pops back up totally
uh yeah and there's just something very
nice about you know these weird paths
that that my stories taken things fell
apart that you start somewhere you've
got no idea how this is going to be
relevant to our lives often until 25
minutes into the show right uh and I
love that I love the kind of audacity
the kind of Storytelling audacity of it
and tell the other kind of big reason I
wanted to make this show was I've
noticed well you know in 2015 I brought
out this book so you've been publicly
shamed which is like you know they
helped Define cancel the cancel culture
without necessarily calling it that it
wasn't even that term didn't even exist
then um so I've been kind of interested
in this stuff for 10 years but I I
started to notice you know more and more
friends falling apart on social media
and obviously everybody knows this now
they've Everybody's Got Somebody in
their life who you know between this
tweet and that tweet two weeks later has
completely changed they've become a kind
of extreme caricature of themselves
they've kind of tripled down they've
gone down a rabbit hole that they can't
escape from and their brains have become
like that scene in Poltergeist when you
open the door and everything's spinning
around really fast and I was just so
interested in the kind of mechanics of
that how how did that happen do you
think that's mostly a function or or not
mostly but in many ways as a function of
social media in the sense that we are
now privy to more of everybody's
thoughts and you know and it's the type
of thing where you will say you know it
could be a politician or an intellectual
or a friend where most of the time you
don't hear every brain fart they
have and then suddenly they'll be like
this law is going to have this kind of
effect on the economy and the next thing
they'll be like you know oh I really
like the color purple or something you
know it's right it's like a Larry King
column come life right where it's just
random thoughts B banal vulgar profane
profound all just strung together yeah I
think I mean a lot of it to do with
being wounded yeah uh you know Twitter
feels like a sort of wounding machine in
the in the the thing I loved most about
Twitter when I when I joined it in about
2009 I guess was it it offered like
little Windows into people's lives into
people's worlds it reminded me of like a
Robert Alman film where
you know his Stephen Fry with his
million Twitter followers stuck in an
elevator and he's live tweeting being
stuck in an elevator and right
underneath that is somebody with 100
Twitter followers who's got some mental
health condition and you're getting a
window into that and it was a place to
be sort of delighted and curious in its
early days and people just bringing up
old stuff right or or like showing clips
of things or hipping you to something
you wouldn't have encountered and it was
like a
it was a place for for DH shaming back
then people would admit shameful secrets
about themselves other people go oh my
God I'm exactly the same it was a
kindhearted and I hate to use this word
I'm sure I could think of a better word
sort of Healing Place yeah and then
instead of it being a place where people
would admit shameful secrets about
themselves it mutated into a place where
we would hunt for people's shameful
secrets and instead of having a kind of
delighted look into other people
people's lives we would find fault and
we' start to wound people and I think
one thing that's happened is there's
been
a almost like a sort of epidemic of
narcissism uh
that
narcissists if you wound a
narcissist then it's really hard they
don't seem to have the kind of
psychological capability of getting out
of that soone said they just lash out
and lash out and lash out then uh I just
follow up on the the psychology here why
you know the one thing you can do with a
narcissist especially on Twitter is just
walk away right you don't have to engage
them why do you think so many people are
willing to kind of keep the conversation
going because we've we've created a
world for ourselves where we Define
ourselves as being in opposition to
other people yeah which is a very
unhealthy well you can see I mean
Society is very unhealthy right now and
that's one reason for it I think you
know instead of curiosity we reach for
judgment I didn't want to make a show
that was about issues I wanted to make a
show that was about stories human
stories so I wanted to take all of this
mess and bring it down to like beautiful
surprising stories uh which you do and
in the you know the first episode of
season 2 which is really about how Co
everybody went mad in Co and what's
great about it is like I wouldn't say
you're quite an equal opportunity of but
like you know it's like you you know the
premise of the show is all of us kind of
went nuts because we all had Cabin Fever
on some level um but you start the the
program starts in Miami in the
1980s and it's about a bunch of weird
murders can you talk a little bit about
excited delirium and what that means
it's such a c this is it's such a crazy
story and a story that really should
have been a lot better known and I think
the reason why it wasn't better known is
because of prejudice so yeah Miami in
the'80s 32 women are found dead in
mysterious
circumstances they have certain things
in common they're all black sex workers
they're all found naked from the waist
down in similar situations like
junkyards um and low levels of cocaine
are found in their systems and the other
thing they have in common is that the
police were
confounded one police officer in the
very small amount of media that covered
these deaths you have to imagine CU
people just don't care about black sex
workers very much uh the police said
this is the most mysterious deaths we've
ever come across because there was no
sign of cause of death no gunshots no
stab wounds nothing um so the deputy
chief medical examiner of the time Dr
Charles wetley declared that he'd s he'd
cracked the case he said the women had
all spontaneously dropped dead as a
result of a combination of cocaine and
sex uh they'd had sex all makes sense
right yeah I I said that to you must
know Nancy rlan yeah I said that to
Nancy romman while I was in the middle
of making the show and she said well how
come I'm not
dead so so
um
um yeah they they'd had sex the sexual
excitement had somehow combined with the
COA in their body and they had
spontaneously dropped dead and he gave
it a name uh excited
delirium so
then a 14-year-old girl called antonet
Burns turns up dead without cocaine in
her system and she wasn't a sex worker
so that was like the first significant
kink in this Theory and then a woman
turns up alive and says she was having
sex with a guy and he quote went from a
nice gentleman to a damn Maniac tried to
choke her so now they had a suspect and
it turns out that it was it was an
excited delirium it was a serial killer
I mean aam's Razer you would have
thought from the beginning of course
this is a serial killer serial killer
called Charles
Williams um but none of this daunted Dr
wetley he just left Miami left the
Scandal behind him and carried on
promoting this theory of excited
delirium uh and it stopped being about
women actually it started being about
men women after the scandal in Miami
there aren't that many cases of women
being diagnosed after death with excited
delirium but it was it all became about
men men go berserk they take too much
drugs they rip off their clothes they
you see them running through traffic
yeah they're like the Incredible Hulk
right they just yeah superhuman strength
impervious to pain and then they
spontaneously drop dead um so so that
became the new you know and the reason
why excited delirium endured when it
really should have gone the way of
Hysteria right it's kind of like a male
version of Hysteria right it's taking
these male traits and pathologizing them
particularly black male you know
caricature traits superhuman strength I
mean so on so um uh so wetley and some
of his protes are all promoting this
Theory and so are taser taser buy up
1500 copies of this book called excited
delirium syndrome and give it to every
forensic pathologist in America because
that sort of Suits them down to the
ground because if somebody dies in
police custody after being tased uh they
can say oh here's here's another
possible explanation so taser promotes
it wetley promotes it it starts getting
to taught in U police training schools
Across America pictures of the Hulk in
these PowerPoint pictures of the Hulk or
Jack Nicholson in The Shining next to
phrases excited next to phrases superum
strength impervious to pain and who
learns about excited delirium and how
you have to restrain them right um Derek
Chauvin and as they stood around George
Floyd's body they were discussing
excited delirium so there's a very
direct path from from from these murders
in Miami to to to George Floyd in the
middle of lockdown and and the reason
why I first wanted to tell that story is
because I wanted season two of things
fell apart to all be about culture wars
that sprung up during lockdown yeah and
it's you know the the idea of uh excited
delirium it changed I mean what you're
talking about is a decades long shift in
the way police handled deescalation of
conflict so instead of doing kind of
various types of deescalation it became
heavy on on tasing people using tasers
um restraining them Etc and leading to
the types of circumstances similar to
the one that George Floyd died dur right
and um yeah because it's all about you
know they're out of control they a
danger to themselves they are danger to
other people you have to restrain them
and yes as somebody says in in in my
show when somebody's tased they're often
not just tased they're beaten up they're
heavily restrict Tred and so on so it's
impossible to say in a lot of the cases
what the cause of death actually is cuz
all sorts of brutality is done to these
people but it's not excited delirium
because excited delirium doesn't exist
right some people listening to this will
presumably be thinking what I was
thinking at the time which is well we've
always seen videos of some guy in
Florida running down the street acting
crazy so I said to a forensic
pathologist you know is excited delum
ever uh a term that should be used and
she said no it could be because it could
be anything it could be diabetes melitus
it could be a reaction to some dodgy
drug from you know spice drug from Asia
that I've never heard of um calling it
all excited delirium putting it all into
that box that's what causes the trouble
um with that um you know there's a new
documentary out that argues that George
Floyd did Derek chovin did not kill
George Floyd Etc does that change your
at all well I didn't that documentary
came out after we finished that
particular show so I didn't go down a
rabbit hole about that
um in a sense kind of not really though
because I'm looking at this yeah junk
science that flourishes in high
important
places um I mean the the excited
delirium uh conversation was certainly
in the Rodney King beating where you
know you watch video of it you know when
you see somebody who is surrounded by
cops who cannot threaten them because
he's you know and they keep beating him
and each time he moves Etc so yeah
exactly yeah I mean right from my book
the menic goats I've been interested in
pseudo science in important places yeah
you know men goats is about craziness
inside the CIA and you know Army
intelligence and so on it would be more
interesting to report on the sanity
within the CIA perhaps particularly
During certain aspects of the Cold War
right there was a yeah exactly there was
a um a psychologist at the time called
Ray Hyman who was asked to evaluate the
psychic spying program in the CIA so I
met him afterwards and I said well how
come you know how come there's so much
craziness inside the
CIA uh and he said because people are
basically nuts so you're going to get
nutty people everywhere including inside
the CIA so yeah
so um I've always been interested in
that in in pseudo science and irrational
thought in powerful important places so
for me excited delirium is another
example of that yeah courtroom junk
science um you you know another episode
uh focuses on Judy mikitz um who is she
and how does she end up contributing to
the kind of mad discourse of of the
covid lockdown era right J magfit is a
story that's exactly the kind of story I
wanted to do for things fell apart
because here's an example of a smart
person who falls down a rabbit hole and
as far as I can tell just can't get out
of it again becomes this kind of extreme
caricature of herself so she and and why
why did that happen so she was a
scientist she worked for the National
councel Institute gave it all up for
love moved to California to be with her
husband David starts volunteering at a
local Yacht Club and to cut a long story
short at the Yacht Club she hooks up
with this group of
people um some very rich people with
children sick with a mysterious illness
chronic fatigue syndrome she starts
working for this
institute trying to find a cure for
chronic fatigue syndrome or or even find
the cause of it and after a couple of
years announces in a huge Fanfare in
Science magazine
uh that they've determined the cause of
chronic fatigue syndrome it's a little
known Mouse virus called
xmrv so and loads of us are walking
around asymptomatically with this
infectious disease this mouse virus
giving each other chronic fatigue
syndrome so this was like a huge deal so
after science published her
findings the government spends Millions
trying to back it up or disprove it and
nobody can replicate Judy's findings and
Judy doubles
down um you know science starts saying
you know you've got to retract like
nobody can back up your findings and a
counter narrative started which was
maybe the um materials that she was
using in her experiments these cell
lines maybe they were infected with xmrv
but never it was never in the blood of
the people that she was testing it was
in the materials but Judy refused to
accept it and became very hostile
refused to hand over her stuff like her
bosses at The Institute were like hand
over the cell lines and she's like no
I'm not going to have you know she
became very protective of her findings
she ends up getting
fired she goes on the run the police are
after her because she took her own noteb
or colleague of first took her notebooks
now she's hiding out on a boat and the
and the police are because of this
employment you know conflict um and then
she be she becomes so I mean my theory
anyway is that she becomes so bruised
and wounded by this terrible situation
when she ended up in jail for five days
um she then
reemerges early in the pandemic with
this documentary called
planemic which
arguably was her revenge on the on the
medical Comm Community it was her
revenge there are people out there who
if they're hurt will dedicate the rest
of their lives to seeking revenge and I
I guess let's talk about planemic and uh
the the creator of that Mickey Willis
who you also talked to who's a former
child actor or wouldbe child actor who
had a brother who died from
AIDS um and how does you know I mean
part of what you're talking about in in
this season of things fell apart is the
way that all of these different strands
kind of come together and just explode
during the pandemic so yeah what does
Mickey Willis do with his you know his
Judy mikovich story well so Mickey
Willis yeah he has he has a couple of
really bad blows as a Young Man one is
he goes to Hollywood he's a very you
know handsome young man goes to
Hollywood signs with an acting coach and
then the acting coach tries it on with
him he refuses and he gets kicked out of
the acting class right and at the same
time his brother has AIDS and is dying
of AIDS and Mickey gets it into his
head um that it's not the AIDS that's
killing his brother it's the treatment
it's act now Act was from what I can
tell like a brutal treatment with
terrible side effects you know these
AIDS patients have to basically decide
whether to die or go blind I mean these
were terrible times but and the early
treatments including a were often
overprescribed or misprescribing
to cure the thing could be as bad it's
kind of like
chemotherapy sometimes you die of
chemotherapy rather than cancer if it's
Mis
misaligned uh I believe like I'm no
world expert on act but I
believe that if there were deaths from
AC like specifically from act there were
almost none and it wasn't a disease that
killed people like they they uh it
wasn't a joke that killed people that's
just that's what I've been told um but
uh yeah so between these two things
Mickey became again like ejected from
the community this is what I read about
and say You' been publicly shamed just
the pschological turmoil that being
ejected from the community can bring but
these are people also like who the
people you're talking about unlike at
least in certain cases unlike some of
the people were publicly shamed science
writer jonair or Justine Saker the
publicist whose tweet about AIDS in
Africa cost her her career and life um
these are people who punch back right
they don't kind of slink away yes and
it's so interesting that change that
happened there's actually a moment in so
you've been publicly shamed I interview
a man called Max Mosley uh it's funny
everybody when whenever people think
about that book they always think about
Justine sacko because she really was
like the ground zero of shaming on a
plane oblivious to disrup Patient Zero
patient zero yes uh just she for people
who don't know she's about to get on a
plane to Cape Town she tweets going to
Africa hope I don't get AIDS just
kidding I'm white
now look you don't have to be a IUS to
figure out what she was trying to do
there she was trying to be like South
Park or R human she was actually making
a liberal joke mocking her own privilege
by doing an exaggerated version of it
and by the time she lands in Cape Town
and she's not online because this is at
a time when you yeah no go go on that
place yeah well she lands in Cape Town
uh turns on her phone and the first text
is in somebody she hasn't spoken to
since high school that said I am so
sorry to see what's happening to you
right
now and you know she's lost her job
she's forever the AIDS tweet woman it
must have ruined her vacation right
people were people were in bars all over
America tweeting like I'm dying to go
home but I can't until Justine sako's
plain LS it was hilarious to people like
torture right it was a form of torture
what we were doing to that night anyway
you she slunk away she she did what
everybody was doing back then which was
apologizing and and going quiet but
there's another person in that book
called Max Mosley who did the opposite
and he his story actually turns out to
be maybe the more relevant to the way
Society has gone now so max his father
was a fascist Oswald Mosley like
Britain's fascist leader um he's a big
character in uh peaky blinders osw
Mosley okay I've got to get around to
pey blinders I've been wanting to watch
it uh so I really we just finished
fiding night l so we're looking for
something new to watch that's a boring
digression yes so
um uh Max has a good career like he's a
Formula One a bit like Ralph nater he's
like a lot to do with car safety Formula
1 Guy one day he goes to the newsst and
there's a photo of him on the front of
the news of the world with the headline
uh Formula 1 boss son of fascist leader
in sick Nazi orgy so the photograph is
Max in sort of SNM gear getting
spanked uh and of course Max's first
thought was like aell you know it's all
over but then he thinks to
himself the ory was undoubtedly German
themed but there was no narcissism so he
su because he's Rich he can do this he
sues the news of the world and the poor
News of the World journalists have to go
through every frame of this great video
they shot looking for swas stickers and
there weren't any so max wins the case
and becomes like a hero
for sex positivity I guess and um one of
us I can't I could for the life of me I
can't remember whether he said it to me
or I said it to him but what we agreed
was that the reason why he endured when
somebody like Justine scko slunk
away was his
realization that a shaming is a PCT
between a shamer and a sham and if the
Sham refuses to be shamed there's
nothing they can do the shamer is just
slink away that's what and then you
started to see that happening more and
more with Trump with Ralph noram the
Virginia governor yeah who was either in
blackface or a Klux Clan Hood in his
right medic school yearbook yeah not not
18 by the way as far as I remember he
was like 25 he did this no no and and he
did he never said which one he was
although he was a Michael Jackson
impersonator so he was probably the one
in blackface right yeah but he he just
refused to leave refused to leave and it
happened again people slunk away um now
you know I
have people I think people probably
assume that I'm all in favor of that and
in some ways I guess I could I I am if
it if you've been disproportionately
shamed for some
something that you don't deserve Justin
sacka for instance I felt was a yeah
wildly disproportionate shaming she was
just trying to be like South Park um and
it you know completely upended her life
but but there's very negative as far as
I can see there's really negative
consequences well talk a little bit
about Mickey Willis because he he became
a documentarian and he did the film
planemic which kind of mainstreamed a
particular type of conspiracy y theory
about Co that included because and this
is the a or the AIDS you're tie in is
that Anthony fouchi uh who I'm no fan of
I must say um and who you know has kind
of admitted that he's lied or dissembled
at various points in public discourse
but he was involved in you know the the
attempts to kind of figure out how to
how to help people with AIDS so he was a
villain lingering in uh Mickey's
subconscious right yeah cuz Mickey
wrongly as far as I could tell thought
that act which actually F she actually
really didn't have anything to do with I
mean from what I understand in in the
AIDS crisis days Anthony fouchy was
doing very much what he's doing you know
during the pandemic which was to be like
the public face of science but wasn't
involved in the development or the
promotion of I mean there are depending
on who you talk to he held back you know
or he the the way the FDA and other
health authorities during AIDS were
really trying to slow walk stuff and it
was the gay community really pushing
people to say like get you know get out
of our way we're dying anyway let us try
things yes and yeah he was slow to the
gate but later on as far as I know as
far as I understand he was Paramount and
and this is getting slightly out of my
sphere of so I apologize if what I'm
about to say is wrong but as far as I
understand he was like Paramount in in
promoting the idea of a cocktail of
drugs So
eventually millions of lives were saved
to a to a point now where we don't we
think of AIDS more as a chronic
condition that is managed rather than a
death sentence right but yeah to Circle
back to all that um Mickey Willis Judy
movitz and a lot of other people I can
think of some of whom in my personal
life some of whom in the show are much
more like Max Mosley it's like they just
refuse it's like the woke yeah I
refuse to be shamed him I'm going
to double down and it's partly the fault
of the shame
and that we overused our
weapon but they're like they've become
like the transgressors have become like
Hospital super bugs impervious to
treatment now because because of the
overuse of Shame and that's not a
healthy I don't I don't see that as a
healthy thing no no well and with the uh
the Mickey uh Willis Story one of the
other threads that you add and this is
to me what makes the show so powerful as
one of the other strands then is Star
Wars right and can can you explain how
you know something that is related to
Star Wars kind of weaves through to why
a documentary like planemic which I
think it's like the Fast and Furious
franchise there's you like 10 of them or
the Star Wars franchise but what is what
is the Star Wars angle all this this was
amazing to me and a real Gap in my
knowledge um in fact what we're
recording this in Greenwich Village and
I I spent about a week walking around
grenwich Village listening to every
podcast interview that Mickey Willis did
to try and find find some some way in
for me and suddenly he starts talking
about Joseph Campbell's Heroes Journey
which I've never heard of and I think I
might be the only person in the world
never heard of it I don't know why I
don't know how you graduate from high
school without having heard of a hero
with a thousand faces right I did C High
School didn't teach
it too busy beating each other up I
suppose but yeah so so it was a great
rabbit hole for me to go down completely
like virgin because I knew nothing about
it and yeah so um Mickey Willis like a
whole load of people including someone
texted me the other day um Andrew Tate
is another example of somebody who's
dedicated their lives to living like the
hero in Joseph Campbell's hero's journey
so Joseph Campbell's hero's journey for
that one other person listening to this
who's never heard of it was this idea
that uh it's a it's um it's a it's it's
in video games it's in movies it's just
a narrative structure hero enters a new
world there's threshold Guardians
there's mentors there's people trying to
stop them and then they fight the dragon
and then they win and they're the hero
uh now I spoke to somebody from when
when I heard Mickey Willis rapid dising
about the hero's journey I just I just
thought that's very interesting so I
spoke to the Joseph Campbell Foundation
who's who said to me yes this was all
popularized by George Lucas right and
Bill Moyers the the American broadcaster
who did a whole thing with Joseph
Campbell called The Power of myth right
that brought in George Lucas who Al also
was clearly
retrofitting right you know the so yeah
it's weird right um and Mickey Willis
saw that those vhs's in a bookstore in
San Francisco and changed his life and
he wanted you know he thought of the
hero's journey as a way for him to live
his life as a self-help book yeah as
opposed to literary right observations
about story structure so I think there's
an amazing story out there and I I may
do more on it myself
about how people are wrongly utilizing
the heroes because if you're a
documentary maker you know you shouldn't
like Micky Willis yeah you shouldn't see
the world in terms of Heroes and Dragons
life's more complicated than that I'm
constantly banging on in my TED talks
and everything about how people are gray
areas we're a mix between hero and this
is you know and and I don't think it
gives away the you know the pleasure of
the different episodes are you start out
with something you know it's and you
know that seems totally remote from
today and then you bring it around to oh
this helps explain the past couple of
years and you certainly do that with
that but you you say at the end you know
he the hero versus the dragon or the you
know that the hero's journey makes sense
for art particularly movies like Star
Wars or you know the Lion King is a
classic example of this um but then in
documentaries you know in real life
people are neither Heroes nor dragons
completely um how does Mickey respond to
that
um kind of prevaricated he he didn't
really he didn't really answer the
question when I put it to him yeah he
was basically that we've all got you
know we we could all be like Anthony
fouchy we've all got the um proclivity
of like turning evil so he didn't really
he didn't really grapple yeah he didn't
grapple with it one of the things that
you show in that and I mean for me this
is you know there there are various
things when I'm listening I'm like okay
I agree with this I I disagree with that
I I have a negative P appraisal of
Anthony fouchy overall for various
reasons uh including his Noble lies
given during covid you know like oh
don't wear a mask they don't work oh I
was saying that because we needed to
save masks for you know First Responders
that kind of crap but um you the people
you talk to you actually pull out their
Humanity so like you're not you I
obviously you don't want to trust your
medical research to Judy mikitz but you
work to understand her yes I where does
that come from like how do how do you
engender that kind of EMP empathy you in
all of your work I mean and I think this
is and I'm I'm this is one of the
reasons why I wanted to talk to you but
also like you know share your mindset
with our audiences that you f you try to
present the other person's point of view
as fairly as possible no matter how
bizarre or insane it might seem yeah I
think I think that the sort of changed
me I remember thinking when I was
starting to write so you've been
publicly shamed uh that I've kind of
gone from the prosecution side to the
defense side like somewhere along the
line I don't think I was ever like total
prosecution but for instance in my book
then when I sneak into Bohemian Grove
with Alex Jones right like I really know
where I stand on on all of that and uh
you hate Bohemian Grove I think Alex was
very much um
mischaracterizing what we saw inside
Bohemian Grove we didn't see an actual
human sacrifice um but yeah somewhere
along the line I think was when I was
writing my book The psychopath test I
just s thinking you people are we're
complicated like there's there's great
values to mental health labels but also
we're complicated and sometimes you
don't want to reduce people to a
diagnostic label and then and then I you
know I'd watch on Twitter everybody
getting reduced you know to to to some
poorly judged words in a tweet and like
everything about their life did no
longer matter it's just they are this
thing they're this one tweet like
Justine scko her tweet is the only thing
that matters about her in her life and I
started to think this is just it's
pseudo scientific it's it's it's it's
just wrong on every level curiosity is
so much more important than instant
judgment you I mean your work in many
ways is a an ongoing critique of the
media um it's you know because like
individuals you know they're going to
live their lives or whatever but those
of us in the media should do more
engagement and trying to figure things
out in one of the episodes uh which is
titled spicy Brando um you talked to a
guy who got caught up in the
supposed uh plot
conspiracy to kidnap and hold for ransom
the governor of Michigan right um first
off explain what spicy Brando is um but
then what did you find out as you delved
into the media coverage and actually the
the legal prosecution of the people
involved with in this plot right uh so
spicy Brandon was a sandwich I was in
two Ms about calling the show spicy
Brando I actually called it the show
that as a joke and then just I never
changed it um spicy Brer was the
sandwich that he had every night uh at
work he worked as a machinist and a Ford
plant and everyy had ph up Subway and
Order his spicy
Brando uh I can't remember what it was
but they named it after him anyway one
night he ERS his sad spicy Brando eats
it somebody says oh
um the boss wants to see you so he goes
to the boss's office and it's one of
those offices where you know you walk in
it's dark and then the lights come out
automatically um through movement anyway
he walks into his boss's office and the
light doesn't come on and he thinks uhoh
and then immediately 15 guys just tackle
him to the ground you know stop
resisting the thing that made me laugh
and I said it to Brandon was that this
is what you've been training for
a member of a kind of like militia group
right training constantly for a moment
exactly like that when it happens he
blows it yeah what happens in that case
though is that you know it kind of turns
out and this the Press seemed less
interested as this unveiled that of the
10 or 12 if even you know people who
were plotting like half of them were FBI
informants right or agents provocator
and they really were provocative like
they were saying come with a you know oh
we've got a great new site I'll pay for
the hotels don't worry you know so it
was a real cluster that that case
um but actually I ended up veering into
a slightly different thing about that
case which is less well chronicled than
that I mean all the undercover Federal
stuff is really fascinating and funny
and startling but there was something
else about that case that I found even
more startling and it's something I
actually look at in this other show that
I made for audible last year called the
debutant similar thing it's why is there
this um drive to
call everybody in a gun club in Michigan
or
whatever white supremacists who are not
just white supremacists but white
supremacists who are out to kick start
an ethnic based Civil War that's a
really specific allegation a really
specific way of seeing them like they're
not a loose Collective
of nuts some of whom with
really objectionable views right but
they're a coordinated conspiracy of
white supremacists who were trying to
start an ethnic-based Civil War and you
there's a couple of books out there that
are really promoting this idea one is
called uh bring the war home and another
one is called House ofil War St mhm and
I'm just not sure how true that is and
so I I dig into that in in spicy Brando
and I think that for me that's the most
interesting part of the story because
it's all about data models basically
without going into too much detail and
people should should listen um this
notion is actually coming from research
conducted overseas and not Research into
American militia groups or um
anyway there's a whole fascinating
Rabbit Hole there which I look into in
spicy brand and I also look into it in
the debutant um it's a really
interesting area yeah and I mean there's
a paranoid cult you know there's a
paranoid element in American politics
which often gets ascribed only to kind
of right-wing nuts but in fact it's in
the center it's on the left like we're
always trying to draw that kind of
extreme attention that the facts that
actually support and I think that's
really important that obviously the
mistake when you're looking at cultural
issues is to do it in a partisan way
right and what you just said is
absolutely true there is irrational
thought on the right you know and these
sort of you know untruths these lies
happen on the right they happen in the
center and they happen on the left it's
a it's a it's a holistic thing the other
uh just point and then I have a couple
of other um larger kind of thematic
questions but in one of the episodes you
talk with the author you talk about how
the overuse of the term or the the
globalization of um of trauma has
undergirded a lot of our responses
particularly under covid which was you
know an amped up highly anxiety inducing
state but you talked to the author of a
book called the body keeps the score um
which went from a well-respected but
little read academic book to one of a
kind of major text of our time can you
talk what was the body keeps of score
about and how did the author tell you
his Concepts were being misapplied in
everyday life right yeah but the body
keeps of score turns out to be lockdowns
biggest non-fiction bestseller it was
number one for ages it sold millions of
copies and it's an academic pretty
boring academic book about PTSD and
complex PTSD I know there's a whole
bunch of people out there who
who very much dislike that book for lots
and lots of reasons there's a whole body
of thought about complex PTSD being
pseudo scientific anyway I don't I don't
go into any of that but I think but
other people but it's an interesting
area I think if people want to go down
what I'm interested in is is you know
the concept group of the term drama so
the body keeps the
score even if you are critical of Bessel
van deul the author of that book what he
says in my show is I think hard to
criticize he says that yeah PTSD is for
people who've been in war or who've been
raped or who've you know committed you
know who've experienced the most
terrible
abuse and now trauma is for people who
read texts that that challenge them or
or I mean you talk about students that
read college in Oregon a a you know
famously Progressive school who were
traumatized by the idea that certain
books were being taught in classes they
weren't even necessarily taken yeah and
and oh actually no they were for they
were made to take the course it was
mandatory yeah um but yes they didn't
want to read
Plato they they thought it was traumatic
to read to be forced to read Plato and
so they start protesting like angrily
loudly protesting the teachers and one
of the teachers a woman called Lucia
Valdivia has actual diagnosable PTSD so
here's a woman who has to go to work to
this incredibly hostile work environment
every day um being screamed at for
causing trauma because she wants people
to read Plato and she's the one who has
actual PTSD so there's clearly an irony
there so so yeah I'm looking so in that
episode I'm looking at the the concept
creep of the term trauma and I think the
reason why I really wanted to do that is
because one of the great mysteries of
our time obviously Jonathan height and
other people look into this is how come
all of these debates over free speech
and so on that stayed on campuses for
years including when I was in college in
the 80s you know all of these debates
were being have about fre speech but
suddenly you they explode out of
colleges and into the workplace right
and I've always been really interested
in trying to figure out what happened
what was the Tipping Point and I think
the concept crep of
trauma and how you can't you know if
somebody says you can't publish that
it'll be traumatizing to people right uh
is part of the reason why I think that
that explosion out of colleges and into
media institutions happened how um how
did you spend Co did you uh you know
were you freaked out by it were you like
uh you know this is I'll deal with it
whatever how did you I I was weirdly
like calm at first in fact I TW tweeted
um something along the lines of because
I've got all sorts of anxiety disorders
many tweeted is there anybody else um
with anxiety disorders right now who are
feeling strangely calm and I got like a
thousand responses and and the
overwhelming there was a couple of
people who said I've got generalized
anxiety disorder and I'm freaking out
and I'm offended by what you just said
but almost everyone like 95 % of people
were oh my God I can't believe you bring
that up yes I've why why did you feel
calm to yourself I I I wonder could it
be that we've spent our
lives know thinking about catastrophic
situations and so I mean I think the
real truth is is that anxiety is a weird
disorder in that you always worry about
stupid right
um uh if I can't get my wife on the
phone she must be dead and I've I've
lost so much of my life to those kinds
of completely irrational worries but
when something genuinely anxiety and
juing happens to people like us we we
kind of deal with it with a plum like
I've been in Jihad training camps where
people have surrounded me and asked me
if I'm Jewish similarly kuku's clown I
was at area Nations one time and all
these skin heads were like asking me if
I was Jewish and you are Jewish and I am
Jewish and and Welsh Welsh yeah even
worse that's yeah for the Aran Nation
they might be like oh that's honorary
Aryan yeah so it does balance out a bit
um but I handled that really well so
there is something weird about anxiety
there when it's something genuinely
anxiety in happens you think that we you
know what you know we've evolved to be
able to deal with like difficult things
but our environment certainly for the
past 50 years doesn't you know we we
don't have any real stuff to worry about
you know most of us so you end to you
fixate on yeah so then when
something more real comes along you
actually can deal with I guess cuz that
certainly is how it is in practice like
when it was clear that we were all about
to go into
lockdown yeah I was the one going
to the chemists to buy the hand
sanitizer like it's like I know what to
do here I know how to deal with this do
you think overall you know was Co
overhyped well or how do we deal with
that because obviously Co was real
people died from it we rolled out
vaccines that were effective in you know
record time um but you know it what I
guess in a way I I guess I'll just say
like we clearly overreacted in many
profound ways um but we're through that
now what are the lingering effects of
this shock to our kind of body politic
right and I should say that even though
I was calm to begin with during lockdown
I would definitely after a few months
find myself letting out little shrieks
as I'm like running down the country Lan
so it was impacting it was snaking its
way into my brain in whether I think it
was snaking it way into lots of people's
brains um well one of the legacies seems
to be that all of this Brewing culture
War rage that was kind of been brewing
since I guess 2012
2013 and so You' been publicly shamed
I've been I I I think you know I I come
down to like 2012 2013 as being when it
all started
um really exploded during covid we were
locked inside becoming all the more
suspicious of our neighbors and our
institutions um and often our
institutions did let us down sometimes
they didn't sometimes but yeah
um and as I said earlier we we began to
Define ourselves as being in opposition
to other people more and more possibly
because we were just left at home with
the internet for company partly because
people did feel let down by
institutions uh um and I guess that's
the lasting thing is we've become way
more
entrenched way more caricatures of
ourselves um funny enough Jordan
Peterson makes two appearances in season
two of things fell apart in the first
appearance he's offering young men well
Brandon Brandon sensible advice about
self-esteem yeah like you know shave you
know work out make your bed that type of
stuff yeah be somebody you know that
you're proud of yeah and I I read 12
rules for life and I thought this is all
good stuff you know I found myself um
bantering with a Workman in a way I
might not have done
it it definitely kind of proded at my
mess in a very unusual way for me but
yeah and then but then the second
appearance of Jordan Peterson is he's
spreading conspiracy theories about
15minute cities that don't hold up to
scrutiny right people really
do did become kind of extreme carico of
themselves and I think lockdown had a
lot to do with it and that by the way
the 15-minute City episode you talk
about this is you know about CL Schwab
and the world economic forum and the
whole idea of the great reset what is
fascinating about that as you look at
the various threads including the guy
who came up with what became known as
the 15minute city which isn't what the
guy was talking about but you do get
people at the world economic Forum well
some of them to be like yeah maybe
calling it The Great reset and being
very declarative in our statements at
least one person says oh yeah that was
probably a mistake yeah poor Eda Orin
who's like been completely upended by
all of this she's the one who wrote this
thought experiment essay about imagining
a world in 2030 where you would where
all products would become Services right
so it's like an interesting thought
experiment and especially because it's
like yeah you're not going to own a car
because you're going to use Uber and you
only use your car like 3% of the waking
hour or you know the hours of your life
why own it if you can just rent it for
the minutes that you need it right but
then her the essay got change I mean
yeah retitled and kind of pushed yeah in
a different direction this is when the
world and and it does get into the
slightly uncomfortable area that in a
way you know the world economic Forum of
are to a lar to to an extent to blame
for everything that went on because they
bring out this video uh where they're
advertising Ed's Essay with some smiling
guy and underneath it says you will own
nothing and you'll be
happy yeah it was uh you point out it's
in you couldn't tell if it's a parody of
it or you know was it produced by Alex
Jones or the world economic for Eda
herself I had to tell Eda that that
video wasn't a conspiracy theorist you
know terrified response to the world
economic in her essay but and then they
took the essay down like as if that's
going to make it disappear and cl Schwab
is he's a bond villain right he he has a
German I mean Swiss accent and lives on
a mountain and runs an Institute or
something he's blow yeah they definitely
the world economic Forum definitely did
themselves no favors with that but at
the same time poor e Walkin like she
wasn't she meant no right in fact yeah
she said afterwards there may be
politicians cuz she's said Danish
politician she said maybe politicians
shouldn't try and be as off and imagine
future cities and the the guy the I
guess he's a British traffic engineer
who was I mean the 50-minute city comes
out of his plan to have dedicated bus
lanes to reduce traffic yeah and so he
turns up at chipping Norton Town Hall
which is you know is exactly how you
imagine it is and everyone's like
screaming at him he's like this is I'm
just trying to make bus lanes better
yeah and everyone like they're having
marches with his faces on placards
calling him a traitor so um you know at
the end you you end the series really
with kind of a a great plea for among
other things uh decency and critical
thinking you know because the fact of
the matter is now we you know we're all
consuming all sorts of um of information
I think it's great I suspect you do for
the most part that it's UNG gatekeeper
in the way that you know in the80s God
it was hard to find any information that
didn't come through very you know
particular channels often State
Associated or just like you know giant
corporate news Gathering it you know now
we can we all have the raw material to
build our own narratives and live in
those worlds um we can create our own
you know Heroes Journey um how do we
yeah how do how do we get to a point
where we treat each other with you know
on on a different relationship level
where we're not Alex Jones and we're not
you know just living in a fantasy world
whether it's a right-wing a leftwing
progressive regressive whatever right
and well everything you just said is is
very interesting and I and I yeah I
agree with you like I hate
Gatekeepers um I hate
hierarchies used to drive me crazy going
into TV companies and just begging them
to let me make documentaries for them I
remember when I was writing my book The
psychopath test I'd go into British TV
companies and I'd say like this book is
honestly like it's going to be a hit I'm
really on and it was a hit the
psychopath test you know please let me
make a documentary to go alongside and
they were like No And so when a world
came along where you didn't need
Gatekeepers it was a undoubt it was a
happy world for me
but that doesn't mean that we should be
low slipping standards um the old Legacy
institutions had their biases and their
flaws but
we should not be I I mean look I don't I
don't like Elon musk's world of let's
throw everything in there and let the
people work out what's true and what's
not true what's the alternative then
well my friend I'm going to my friend
Adam Curtis who's who I've you know I've
been like a you know he's he's he's
almost like a sort of mentor to me um
Adam but thinks that there's you know if
if you go on to Twitter
and after you know I was on Twitter
after the Jeffrey Epstein papers were
released and the first thing I see is
you know forgery saying that Jimmy
Kimmel was part of it and just because
there's some Community notes saying no
Jimmy Kimmel isn't this is a forgery
after five minutes I just threw my hands
up and and thought this isn't for me
like I'm not going to be able to figure
out what's true and what's not true and
I and I and this is part part of the
interview where people are going to be
saying I liked John Ranson up until this
point but I don't like him anymore I
scuttled back to the Legacy Media for
and and I think and this is what Adam
said to me that you know if social media
if these if this gatekeeper lless
Society is going to be like a John
Carpenter movie from the 80s of all of
these Warrior gangs you know attacking
each other then most
people are going to Scurry away to
somewhere safer because most people
don't want to live and Escape From New
York or the
we want a safe world and I think if if
if this gatekeeper World continues to be
the kind of cluster fact that it is with
no real standards about what's true and
what's not true inevitably there's going
to be a return to to the Legacy Media do
you think that's underway or do you
think you know is it possible that we
learn you know that everything is not
just you know going one back and forth
that maybe there is a dialectic where
there leads to a synthesis so you know
in a world uh where you know we we've
we've seen Gatekeepers we've seen the
explosion of kind of unfettered Internet
uh empowered media uh including things
like social media Etc and then people
start going to places like substack or
you know people build a
reputation that exceeds just whether or
not people agree with them
ideologically I mean things like
substack patreon or whatever you know I
can absolutely say you know there's
something nice about people who've been
you know excluded from the culture can
still have a life on substack there's a
practical problem actually though which
is that you can only really do well on
substack and places like it if you
produce a hell of a lot of stuff like if
you bring stuff out like every week or
two or three times a week you can do
very well on substack and I've got
friends who are doing incred incredibly
well on
substack uh but for someone like me who
produces like three hours of content in
Year we're kind of like like the
only way we can make money is through
the Legacy Media is through you know
things fell apart was for the BBC a lot
of my podcasts were for audible right
for somebody like me I have to and it's
funny to say audible of course is not
the Legacy Media right audible is a
company owned by yeah and how how old is
it right it it's a 21st century
phenomenon yeah and even Channel 4 right
you do a lot of stuff for them so that's
like yeah you know an offshoot of the be
right well they're they're different to
the BBC but I can see why people get
them mixed up you know they're both like
public Ser or have been through periods
of like you know Public Service
education and so on so I mean I guess
for me the respon you know the the
answer is that it's going to be a
patchwork I would never want to go back
to a um you know three broadcast
networks
pre- um you know and i' I just I've
evacuated those and I live in a
different world but like it's a
patchwork of Legacy Media the New York
Times oddly is probably more important
now than it's ever been even if it can't
really open and close Broadway plays and
things like that um but we have all this
other stuff and it's up to us to kind of
figure out how do we navigate this stuff
critically it's definitely up to us
people oh when saving publicly shame
came out people got really annoyed with
me for not doing a a sort of chapter at
the end where I do a list of you know
almost like a self-help chapter yeah and
I thought God you know I'm not a
lifestyle Guru it's not my job to tell
people how to behave but there was a
real call for that and um I I but the
answer is exactly what you just said
it's up to us if we want the power that
that we didn't used to have but now we
do have it we have to use it responsibly
right we can't just be who make
up um we have to we have to
have high standards and that's when it
comes to shaming people um and it comes
to Bringing out journalism do you feel
like there are in ways with kind of
public shaming and that you know in in
as variance I was thinking about when
I've read some of your work and and
listened to it um you know there used to
be up to some point probably in the
early 90s maybe where if you were a
female performer and I'm thinking of
people like Madonna or Vanessa Williams
the first black Miss America nude photos
come out and then you're done like that
you you're done Madonna kind of broke
the back of that and many other kind of
cultural motifs or mores or something
where it's like you know it's it's not
mandatory that you do a sex tape if
you're a female performer but it doesn't
kill your career the way that it did
yeah 30 years ago and that's good yeah
um but do you think in other ways like
where can we can we be mistaken can we
be you know it the the world in in the
world we live in we can either become
more vituperative and um uh you know
mean to people or we can become more
forgiving because everybody realiz as
we're all idiots through large parts of
our Lives well one you know positive
clue to us being more forgiving is
episode three of season one of things
fell apart is an episode called a
miracle and it's about two Waring
factions coming together in the 80s uh
Christian evangelists and the gay
community and when that episode aired I
can't tell you the number of emails F
you know messages I had from people
saying that they had to pull over the
car because they were crying so hard now
part of the reason why they were crying
was because the lead the main voice in
that episode a guy called Steve Peters
was an extraordinary moving man but I
think also the reason why people were
were crying was because that was a story
in a season about things falling apart
this was an episode about things coming
together and I think people
desperately wanted that without even
realizing that they wanted it um look
where you so much of the culture war is
being fought by
rageful extreme thought leaders
most people like my friend Adam said
about you know the internet becoming
like a John Carpenter movie most people
don't want that yeah and we see that in
real life you know where I live Upstate
is very 5050 trumpy bidy there's no
conflict in our village I mean if there
is it's very small you know everybody
gets on well with each other we all meet
in the in the in the bar at the in the
town and everybody's nice so people
don't want these wars we've just allowed
ourselves to to be led by you know
angry wounded narcissists and addicts
and and and people who want to double
down and become extreme versions of
themselves but most people don't want
that there's times when we think we want
it but we basically don't want it so I'd
like to think that you know deep down
inside all of us is is is somebody who
actually wants Harmony and curiosity and
empathy and kindness instead of rageful
judgment all right we're going to leave
it there John Ronson the
latest uh thing is the second season of
things fell apart thanks so much Nick it
was a pleasure thank
[Music]
you